في افغانستان خلافات واضحه برزت في الاشهر
الاخيره داخل حركه طالبان لتنذر بانقسامات
بين قندهار وكابل بعد سنه ونصف فقط من
حكمها خلافات اساسها تقسيم المنصب بين
قاده قندهار اين يوجد زعيم الحركه ملاهبه
الله وكابول التي يتواجد بها الوزراء
والمسؤولون فازعموا طالبان اليوم لم تعد
لديه ثقه في المسؤولين في كابول الذين
طلبوا باصلاحات داخليه ينادي بها سراج
الدين حقاني الذي يريد تقييد صلاحياته من
ضمن الاصلاحات تشكيل مجلس شورى للحكم لكسر
سيطره الزعيم على القرارات والسماح
للفتيات بالتعليم والعمل والتفاهم مع
الغرب حول النقاط الخلافيه للاعتراف
بحكومه طالبان لكن زعيم طالبان يؤكد بانه
سيتخذ كل الخطوات التي من شانها عرقله
مسار تشكيل هذا المجلس ومن هذا يريد تقييد
السلطات كبار القاده في كابول الذين
يتخوفون من ان يقوم الزعيم بتعيين رئيس
وزراء اموال له والافضل بالنسبه له قاضي
القضاه الحالي عبد الحكيم حقاني حيث ذكرت
وسائل اعلام افغانيه بان وزير الماليه
هدايه الله بدري قدم استقالته بعد خلافات
مع زعيم الحركه على اثر ذلك ذكرت مصادر
العربيه بان زعيم الطالبان يرغب باقاله
رئيس الاستخبارات عبد الحق وثيقه وتعيين
احد القندهاريين حتى يتمكن من الوصول الى
كافه ملفات الاستخبارات في الحكومه
السابقه او الحاليه الا ان جناح وزير
الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني يرفض ذلك
ويتمسك ببقاء وثيق في منصبه ويرفض اي سلطه
اضافيه لقندهار